una partícula que se mueve en el plano x
m tiene como vector velocidad a vettel y
tenemos este vector de aquí observa al
usar esta anotación tenemos a la
componente x del vector velocidad como
una función del tiempo que es uno entre
temas 7 y también podemos ver que la
componente james del vector velocidad es
también una función del tiempo y en este
caso este elevado a la cuarta potencia
para t mayor o igual a cero
/ igual a 1 la partícula está en el
punto 3 4
y no os preguntan cuál es la magnitud
del desplazamiento de la partícula entre
el tiempo te iguala uno y el tiempo te
iguala tres esta es mi primera pregunta
y además me preguntan cuál es la
posición de la particular entre igual a
tres redondea la respuesta a la décima
más cercana y como siempre pausa el
vídeo consigue una calculadora creo que
esta vez la vas a necesitar e intentar
resolver este problema bien ya hemos
resuelto varios problemas como este pero
en una sola dimensión así que es buen
momento para trabajarlo en dos
dimensiones la clave es descomponer este
vector en las componentes que lo forman
es decir si queremos saber el
desplazamiento entonces lo dividiremos
en el desplazamiento en x el cual es
básicamente el cambio en la componente x
y el desplazamiento en el cuál será el
cambio en y después vamos a usar ambos
desplazamientos para encontrar la
magnitud del desplazamiento de la
partícula
desde te iguala uno hasta te iguala tres
usando el teorema de pitágoras y claro
si ya sabemos el cambio en xy el cambio
james podemos sumar el cambio en x a
este 3 y el cambio en yemen a este 4
para así encontrar la posición de la
partícula ente igual a 3 así que
empecemos el cambio en x desde e igual a
1 hasta de igual a 3 va a ser igual a la
integral de la componente x del vector
velocidad desde de igual a 1 hasta de
igual a 3 así que en dirección x tenemos
la función 1 / tema 7
esa es nuestra velocidad x como una
función del tiempo
dt y como encontramos esta integral
bueno podemos hacer una sustitución y si
esto te parece poco familiar o podemos
reconocer que esto es simplemente la
derivada del logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de tema 7
porque observamos aquí está la derivada
de de más 7 la cual es simplemente una
aquí voy a poner uno entonces me queda
el logaritmo natural del valor absoluto
de temas 7 ok y tenemos que evaluar esto
en 3 ya esto quitarle la evaluación en 1
lo que me quedaría el logaritmo natural
del valor absoluto de 10 que bueno eso
simplemente el logaritmo natural de 10
menos el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de 8 lo cual es simplemente el
logaritmo natural de 8 y ahora si usamos
propiedades de los logaritmos vamos a
obtener que esto es lo mismo que el
logaritmo natural de 10 entre 8 lo cual
es el logaritmo natural de 1.25 y puedo
sacar mi calculadora y obtener
fácilmente este valor pero lo voy a
hacer en un segundo antes déjame
calcular el cambio en james y el cambio
james va a ser igual a la integral desde
1 a 3
este es el intervalo de tiempo que nos
interesa
y después tengo que mi componente james
de mi vector velocidad
este elevado a la cuarta potencia de t
y usando el inverso de la regla de la
potencia obtengo que esta derivada es de
quinta en 35 y hay que evaluar esto en 3
y quitarle la evaluación en 1 y entonces
me quedan 3 elevado a la quinta potencia
entre 5 lo cual es 243 en 35 menos uno
elevado a la quinta potencia de 35 lo
cual es un quinto entonces esto me
quedan 242 quintos que es 48.4 y ahora
déjame sacar mi calculadora para obtener
el logaritmo natural de 1.25 el
logaritmo natural de 1.25 es
aproximadamente un 0.22 si lo
redondeamos a dos decimales entonces
déjame ponerlo es aproximadamente 0.22
muy bien
porque ya con esto podemos encontrar a
la segunda pregunta cuál es la posición
de la partícula ente igual a 3 bueno
será la posición que tenemos entre igual
a 1 ya cada una de estas componentes le
vamos a sumar sus respectivos cambios
así que la posición de la particular
ente igual a 3 serán 3 más el cambio en
x desde t igual a 1 hasta de igual a 3,4
más
el cambio en yemen desde t igual a 1
hasta t igual a 3 así que esto va a ser
igual
bueno va a ser 3 más a 0.22 que es 3.22
aproximadamente como 4 + 48.4 lo cual es
52.4 bien ahora que ya resolvimos la
pregunta número 2 habrá que resolver la
primera pregunta cuál es la magnitud del
desplazamiento bueno simplemente hay que
usar el teorema de pitágoras haré un
pequeño esbozo para que lo veas con más
claridad observa por aquí tenemos a
nuestra posición inicial
qué es 34 / igual a 1
y ahora podemos ver que nuestro cambio
en x no es muy grande nuestro cambio en
x es de 0.22 se mueve ligeramente en
esta dirección y nuestro cambio en james
s si es muy grande se mueve
dramáticamente en esta dirección y si
ahora queremos sumar estos cambios
juntos tenemos que encontrar la
hipotenusa de este triángulo y justo la
longitud de la hipotenusa será la
magnitud del desplazamiento que buscamos
es hora de obtener la la magnitud del
desplazamiento va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada del cambio en x al cuadrado más
el cambio en jim al cuadrado y una vez
más simplemente estamos usando el
teorema de pitágoras y cuánto es esto
bueno con la calculadora obtenemos esta
cantidad elevada al cuadrado ok me da
esto de aquí ya esto le voy a sumar 48.4
esto elevado al cuadrado
esta es la suma y bueno a esto le voy a
sacar la raíz cuadrada y por lo tanto
obtengo 48.4 aproximadamente si lo
redondeamos a la décima más cercana
entonces déjame escribirlo estos
aproximadamente 48.4 y lo hemos logrado
por último tal vez estés tentado a decir
que el desplazamiento es lo mismo que el
cambio en jim y puedas confundirte pero
eso no es del todo cierto la razón del
porqué obtuvimos una magnitud del
desplazamiento parecida al cambio en
sport que el cambio en james es
exactamente 48.4 mientras que la
magnitud del desplazamiento es
ligeramente mayor a 48.4 pero la
redondeamos al décimo más cercano por
eso sólo pusimos 48.4 y la razón del por
qué obtuvimos un desplazamiento de 48.4
es porque nuestro cambio en x es muy
recuerdan el cambio en x es de 0.22 lo
que hacen que no se porten usa sea
ligeramente más grande que el cambio en
yemen esta es la razón del por qué
tenemos esta magnitud en nuestro
desplazamiento en ese instante en
particular en general podrás ver que
nuestra magnitud de nuestro
desplazamiento va a ser mayor que
nuestro cambio en x y que nuestro cambio
en kiev perfecto ya está todo así que
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo